can we talk about
world war ii in the soviet union sure
so on sunday june 22nd
1941 hitler launched
operation barbarossa which was the
surprise invasion of the soviet union
that's right if i could read to you a
few lyrics
from a song that for some reason has
stuck throughout my childhood
it was a famous song during that time
the song talks about um kiev
like that moment as part of that
operation that kiev was first bombed and
it was announced on
june 22nd the song says at exactly four
o'clock
that the war has begun for some reason
this song
haunts me because
the exactness of that time and this
realization
that at any moment you could have this
thing happen to you in your own personal
life maybe you had something like 9 11
happen where everything changes
and it's just like haunting because it
makes me think
that at any moment something like that
could happen that changes everything
and i just think about like normal life
going on in kiev at the time
and then all of a sudden the bombs are
dropping
and they announced that the war has
begun and you thought you were
going to stay out of the war um
um this is something that is very
intensely emotional for me
because you and i are both russian
jewish so
to know that my grandparents and my
great-grandma
were told
that the nazis were coming and this
wasn't a dress rehearsal
and that if they get here which they do
they did lev is very western ukraine
that 100
you and all your relatives are going to
be murdered
yeah and uh
there's a monument now in in level where
i'm from about this
but i i don't think either of us can
imagine
what it's like to know
to think that we're about
you know minutes or whatever hours or
there's just there's just the russian
army
standing between us and everyone
everyone
we are related to are going to be
murdered for no reason
and um
you know like what's the closure here
right like they evacuated a lot of
people
and but they didn't evacuate enough and
to know
that there is this force
coming to 100 murder you this isn't some
kind of
you know uh the tv news being hyperbolic
they are coming to kill you
and they if they get you they will kill
you and you have to
you know we all think about war let go
you know we hope america wins in iraq
right but if america got their ass
kicked kind of in vietnam
it's not really going to affect america
in the sense that you're going to have
the body bags and all the kids being
killed and that's something that's i'm
not sweeping on the rug
but no one in america thought the
vietnamese are going to come here and
kill them right they were secure in
their person
so to have that sense of
we really need to win because if we
don't win we are
100 if we they the russian army doesn't
win
we are 100 all going to be slaughtered
and often and not just a bullet to the
head in in sadistic ways
is something that um to know that people
who share my blood
uh saw and went through is very hard for
me to kind of um
uh wrap my head around and there's no
possibility
to delude yourself yeah yeah yeah
because i mean they
they would uh as the song also talks
about but
they would burn the factories so it's
basically saying
we're in the war now this is like this
is your life yeah
this is our life you know how you
yesterday you're worried about like oh i
misplaced my pen
where is it like it's like yeah
this was paradise most of us are gonna
this our life now is that
most of us are going to die
and if we want to prevent all of us from
dying
we uh we have to fight and we also can't
sit down
in some kind of weird like um desert
island or
you know plane crash situation and be
like let's decide
between us who's going to be the first
to die maybe the like titan the titanic
right
they sat down and they were like women
and children in the lifeboats
you know they had this rational
agreement you don't have those choices
in in a war so um
it's it's something that i uh uh
it's it's just very chilling and it's
something i don't really have
um the emotional space to understand or
grapple with
uh even you know obviously i've been to
north korea you can see it and so on and
so forth
you and i can't or anyone listening to
this except for maybe on me and people
like that
you can't imagine what that's like to
live it
we can't i we can't imagine what it's
like to live
in those situations where it's not like
before hitler came
everyone's you know dancing around and
having a great time
i mean imagine how what that life is
like where
your preference to hitler is starving
and waiting online for hours for bread
and to have the secret police and your
friends are turning you in and your
phones are all tapped and you're a
prisoner
but to you this is infinitely better
than the alternative like these are the
choices that you know our family
had to deal with it's something that no
matter how much
you it's like a let me put in terms
people can understand
you know what i mean it's like your
first bad breakup right like that's a
much
simpler thing to wrap your head around
because it's like if you've never had it
you can't really
but when you feel it it's just so
intense but you can't tell someone
what's like
we could sit down for days and hours and
have people tell us
but until it's the totality totality of
your environment and your life and your
mindset
i remember my grandma
um
she would talk about that's like
when you're when you're that hungry
all you're thinking about is bread yeah
because your brain won't let you know
human beings you're revolved we have
instincts whatever and
the mind is telling you food food food
food
food food and that there's kids
thinking this and that there's they're
not going to get the food
yeah uh and imagine being a parent and
you're
watching your kids without food and
knowing
they're not going to get the food and uh
the fact that this happened in north
korea in the 90s yeah i i met a refugee
and he had to watch his dad starve to
death
and uh thank you um
and we have no
concept of uh
what it's like i mean we kind of you
know it's just like
last night here in austin all the places
were closed and i couldn't get my
protein powder
yeah and this is the extent of my
suffering
when it comes to food you know or if i
couldn't there was a restaurant that i
went to in brooklyn
where for some cocktail reason they
weren't serving
sashimi they only had sushi so i had to
have the rice and the carbs
to live a life where that is the extent
of your food problems
as opposed to the choice is either
hitler
killing you or being hungry 24 7. you
know my grandma told this story of how
they had a close call it was her and her
brother and her mom my
great-grandma who passed and i think
there was like either helicopter
overhead or something and my
great-grandma jumped on top of my uh
grandma's brother and not my grandma so
she basically did a sophie's choice
my grandma's name is sophia and chose
the brother
and this is something that she felt you
know all her life that
her mom had chosen her brother over her
but these little things
that happened these little kind of a
decisions we have to make in war there's
a book i read
called uh uh five chimneys i think
this woman who was an auschwitz survivor
and what she talked about what people
don't appreciate it's not
necessarily the slaughter and the
torture it's that
there's no rhyme or reason to it like
she talked about how they had a camp
just for people from
uh czechoslovakia and they were treated
better than
the jews and then one day they just
killed them all right and she's like
i still don't understand why they're
giving them food and treating them well
and then the next day they're all killed
and we will never get answers you know
and she's
and and things like she talks about
how they decided to kill all the kids
and they didn't
really either for some reason they
didn't have the courage to or they
wanted to be cruel
so instead of shooting them they just
kept walking them in the snow until they
all died
so it's things like this that uh the
fact that you and i
dodged these bullets and that we can be
here
and uh be doing this and you know
running our mouths for a living
uh i i think about it all the time and
um
uh it's it's just very um
uh disturbing to know and i know you
know this as well that there's lots of
places on earth
where if people had a choice they would
kill us on site and be proud of
themselves for it
yeah they're i don't know what to make
of the contrast of the you
you were talking about the fact that
you've been truly happy the last
few weeks and months yes there's been a
lot of moments of happiness and joy
and that joy is built on a history
of human suffering like in your roots in
your blood
is a lot of people that were tortured
that suffered so that you could have
this joy
and you have both the you have the
responsibility to truly be grateful for
that joy
but it also shows that there's the happy
ending that it does
end in a good note that it does get
infinitely infinitely better
um and that i think there's a i don't
like using the word responsibility but
there is um an opportunity for those of
us
who did dodge that bullet to uh
give testimony to these people and more
importantly to give testimony to the
people who are going through this
now so you know one of the reasons i you
know talk about north korea so much why
i wrote dear reader
is because it's very easy and this is
human nature i'm not
condemning people i don't i think this
is how people are wired
when you see an asian country with asian
people and things are
you know bad over there you you know i
think in the west it's like oh you know
asia they're all crazy there they're
wacky they eat you know they eat dogs or
someone and so forth some weird
stereotype and they think of them as
kind of martians
so it's important for people who aren't
of that
kind of ancestry to kind of speak on
behalf of these people because it's very
different how just people just naturally
react
when you have a westerner talking about
this instead of becoming
there you know them over there it
becomes you know this could have been
uh us very easily i have a friend peter
they hanski great dude
and i was showing him photos when i was
in pyongyang and he goes this looks like
a russian city with asian people it was
it completely disturbed him
so you know that was one of the reasons
i did go to north korea because that was
as close as i would get to see what your
family went through to see what my
family went through
and they're still living under this
uh a regime and one of the things i
fought very hard to do with dear reader
which i was successful in amazingly and
it just i said like i could die now like
i feel like if you make if just move the
needle a little bit then you've kind of
uh paid your due for
your time here on this earth to have it
change from being a laughing stock
you know and i i think team america did
a good job
they made kim jong il into a clown and
they made a joke of it
but you're going from nothing to jokes
so at least now people are aware of it
that it exists right
and then i st and many others took it
from a joke to like
guys this is really really really bad
and none of us can even appreciate how
bad it is and i think now there is an
understanding
other than a few people who are just
looking through a trump lens and wanting
trump to fail because trump's an [ __ ]
and that's
fine to be like these poor people
and it's really unfortunate because
there's a segment of
western culture who thinks that
correctly
often when you're complaining about or
discussing the plight of another country
that's just your prelude to war
and an excuse to invade like the kurds
in syria you know we're talked about if
we're not in syria tomorrow it's going
to be another genocide blah blah
i'm not saying let's invade north korea
or anything like that all i'm saying
is you know thank god that this is in
your life
i bring this up all the time the woman
who was my guide when i was there
i'm aware of what she's up to now she's
still
she's extremely rich by north korean
standards but she'll never be in a
position to buy medicine she'll never be
in a position to go on a vacation
uh things that you and i just you know
whatever she's she can't go on the
internet
she can't get encyclopedia uh she can't
better herself as a person other than
through what the state allows and
meaning better yourself as a person
in service to the state so i i i mean
there's it's also frustrating because
there's only so much
that i can do as an individual what's
your takeaway about human nature
from looking at north korea and looking
at how the rest of the world is looking
at north korea
uh i i always this is a great question i
think about it fairly often
i always say human beings are animals
right when you say someone's an animal
it's like a slur like he's like a beast
animals are capable of enormous kindness
empathy sympathy you know they look out
for one another
groom one another there's a thing with
with apes where they groom each other
for
parasites and you're supposed even if
there are no parasites they pretend this
parasites just to have that kind of
bonding
uh you see infinite uh photos online of
like cats raising puppies because the
puppies
mom died things like this that's part of
being an animal part of being an animal
is also
just the most uh monstrous cruelty
uh killer whales you know there's this
big pc move did not call them killer
whales and just call them orcas
they will murder blue whale pups
uh cavs excuse me and play with them and
not even eat them so they just murder
for the sake of fun
so there's and cats you know kill birds
all the time things like this so
it runs the whole gamut um and i think
it's
i i'm you know when yaron and i were on
your show i don't think lord of the
flies is accurate i don't think hobbs is
how reality works
when you're in that kind of state um
but i think uh we've seen countless
examples
of human beings especially when human
beings have power
over someone who's powerless of allowing
themselves to engage in
not just harm but cruelty
and that is something as soviets you and
i are very painfully aware of it
it's not just about the oppression which
as bad enough as it is
it's that mediocre person with that
little bit of power
and now they're standing between you and
your daughter having medicine
and they love it to make you dance
to be like oh you need me to get this
medicine make you go
go through hoops because now they feel
like for the first time in their life
they're in a position of strength and
power
i think that is in many ways the more
common nature of evil
what hannah aaron talks about the
banality of evil than someone who's like
an ss guard you're shooting someone in
the head
like that i think we could all wrap our
heads around to some extent like okay
i'm a military
it's not easy i have to execute people
pulling a trigger you could kind of have
this mental disconnect between the
finger and the victim
but like that little day-to-day stuff
like are you doing the right thing on a
day-to-day basis that i think is
far more common and far more disturbing
aspect in certain senses of the human
psyche
yeah there's something um especially
disturbing about
a weak man
given power yeah and just abusing that
power
there's something about not just weak
but like mediocre and everything he does
or less than mediocre a great example of
this which i'm also talking about the
next book is ceausescu
who was the dictator of romania so you
know
the cold war is still somewhat poorly
understood in you know
popular culture but the different
countries in the second world the soviet
bloc
some are more liberal than others some
were more sane than others and
chauchesko
at first was one of the you know more
western friendly more the free ones
then he met the great leader kim sung
from north korea and he had the idea to
impose a personality cult on
romania and it's the kind of things like
forcing people to breed because he
wanted to make people taller
he i think he made like the biggest
building in all of europe the people's
palace but it was just for him
while there's no electricity you know
elsewhere but you look at this guy
you know stalin's a badass right he was
a bank robber if you look at photos of
him as a kid he was a hunk
lenin was clearly intellectual these
were not these were
powerful trotsky these were powerful men
with huge egos huge
force of personality but you look at
this chauchesku guy
and you could like for example on my
driver's license instead of my address
i'm like in my real dress being like
one two three four fifth avenue by
mistake it says one two three four fifth
street
right so you can imagine him being in
the post office and me giving him my id
to get my package and him being baffled
because this says street that says
avenue instead of understand and this
the look on his face this
dullard that you can see how you know
how sometimes i'm gonna can i curse
[ __ ] yes yeah so if you know like how if
you're in the airport and you see
someone and you look at them an adult
and you think okay this person was born
[ __ ] up just like on site like
something's wrong with them how are they
traveling alone
you look at chauchesku you look at him
you're like something's not right with
this guy not in the sense of like evil
but in the sense that he's a simpleton
right
and now he's in charge of this whole
country and everyone's taught to regard
him as one of the great geniuses of all
time
and it's this the idea this mediocre
nobody this guy would have in any other
culture been accomplished
nothing would have had an
honest job where he's like okay he works
at the mail mail service and he's batted
it okay fine he's not hurting anyone
and now as a result of this he's
responsible for mass death
secret police and incarceration and uh
you know the one the greatest things
that i've ever seen which uh i'm sure
many people have seen as well if you go
on youtube it's his speech
and it's the first time the crowd turns
and his head kind of like because they
start booing him
which was unheard of and you know he was
shot with his uh um
dog-faced wife not that long after it
was just a great moment but
it's things like this i agree with you
that that mediocre weak person
is now in a position of power for
somebody else and that sense of
vindictiveness like i'm going to feel
strong for once in my life but it's
going to be at your expense
that i think is you know human nature
it's most primal
and every time i meet a person in this
world you're the first person to get me
to cry on a [ __ ] podcast [ __ ] the
robot gets me to cry what the [ __ ] is
going on
you